Since its inception, filmmaking has
been a space of potential danger.
In fact, it's often the films with
seemingly the least amount of risk
that pose the greatest danger to the actors. From
beloved kids' movies to classic '90s comedies,
these are the surprising scenes that
were actually dangerous to film.
Children and adults alike have loved "The
Wizard of Oz" since its release in 1939, but
beyond the bright technicolor world was a land of
danger, accidents, and poison. The production of
"The Wizard of Oz" has become as legendary as the
film itself, due to its many unfortunate mishaps.
The Wicked Witch of the West was accidentally set
on fire when a trap door malfunctioned during a
scene; the Tin Man got poisoned by his aluminum
heavy makeup; even Terry, the dog playing Toto,
wasn't exempt as one of the Winkie Guards
accidentally stepped on her paw and broke it.
But, surprisingly, one of the most dangerous
moments of all was the poppy field scene.
The Cowardly Lion, Tin Man, and Scarecrow stand
above Dorothy, who lies unconscious among the
poppies as snow starts falling around them. It
turns out, things weren't so gentle — the fake
snow was made of asbestos, a toxic carcinogen. The
dangers of asbestos were known by the early 1900s,
but that didn't stop producers from dousing
Judy Garland and her co-stars with it.
"Now my beauties, something with poison
in it, I think, with poison in it."
In spite of its name, "Grease" didn't run
quite as smoothly as producers had hoped.
The film's climactic racing scene called for
John Travolta and Dennis Stewart to splash
through water that was stagnant and filled with
bacteria. Also, Jeff Conaway slipped and fell
while doing a take of "Grease Lightning," leading
to lifelong back pain and an addiction to opioids.
Ultimately, it was the prom sequence, however,
that proved most dangerous to film. On screen,
viewers can enjoy a vibrant scene
of bright colors, a dance off,
and even John Travolta doing the splits — but
off screen, things weren't quite so fun. The
Los Angeles gymnasium where the dance was filmed
didn't have any air conditioning, and doors were
closed to control lighting. The location got
so hot — a cool and casual 116 degrees — that
several members of the cast had to be helped
off the set due to heat-related illnesses.
While the standard for filming on location in
the middle of a city is to close down the street,
that isn't always available when
you're working on a limited budget.
Such was the case for John Schlesinger, director
of "Midnight Cowboy." In the film, Jon Voight
plays a sex worker who strikes up an unlikely
friendship with Dustin Hoffman's Ratso Rizzo.
The most famous scene of the film
was an accidental one that almost
injured Hoffman. Since production didn't have
the money to shut down the streets, they filmed
Voight and Hoffman walking and talking in
the middle of real New York City traffic.
As they're exchanging dialogue, a cab
driver tried to run through a red light,
nearly hitting Hoffman. This led to a genuine
outburst and a classic moment of film dialogue.
"Hey, I'm walkin' here! I'm walking here!"
1976's "Carrie" continues
to terrify viewers today,
with its Stephen King-conceived tale of a
bullied young woman pushed to her breaking
point. The shoot was intense as Sissy Spacek
was so committed to staying in character
that she isolated herself from her
cast mates, slept in her bloody dress
and even insisted on being buried alive so
she could push her own hand out of the grave.
In spite of all this, it was the
climactic prom scene when Carrie
goes after her tormentors that proved to
be most dangerous. With scenes like this,
filmmakers have to plan carefully to avoid mishaps
but still, things can happen, especially when a
fireman refuses to operate the firehose because
it's too strong and a stuntman does it instead.
PJ Soles, who plays the bully Norma, discovered
this danger first hand when she got sprayed in
the ear with a fire hose. The power was so
intense that she suffered from a ruptured
ear drum for six months and the painful moment
is even included in the final cut of the film.
For "The 40-Year-Old Virgin," Steve Carell
decided to go full Method. Not only did he
write the chest waxing scene for himself, but
he also decided to get his chest waxed for real.
While normally this isn't so dangerous, the
stakes were unknowingly raised with the hiring
of Miki Mia, who lied to the casting
directors about her waxing proficiency.
So, while Carell perhaps anticipated some
level of pain, what he didn't expect was
nearly getting his nipples ripped off as Mia
didn't take the important step of putting
Vaseline around that area. The scene proved
so painstaking to film that actor Romany Malco
had to leave while Carell gritted his teeth
and followed through with the process.
The film's director, Judd Apatow, loves to keep
things real, and Carell's agony was extremely
real. In the end, it was definitely
worth it, at least for the audience.
"Do you know what, guys? This
is not a good look for me."
"The Exorcist" has become as famous for its
terrifying set as for its horror on screen.
It got to the point that people working on
the film actually believed it was cursed.
Ellen Burstyn suffered a permanent back
injury while being yanked by a harness,
several deaths have been linked to the movie,
including cast members and members of their
families, an entire set burned down, and a
priest had to be brought in to bless the set.
Such a physically demanding film, understandably,
has risks but one of the more dangerous moments
came as a result of the director's head-turning
scare tactics. In order to elicit the most
authentic reactions on screen, William Friedkin
would randomly shoot guns on set. Jason Miller,
who played Father Karras, got into an altercation
with Friedkin after he fired a gun next to his
ear to get a surprise reaction. Miller noted
that as an actor, he doesn't exactly need a gun
to be surprised or startled. Friedkin never
denied the claims of using a gun to get a rise
out of the actors; in fact, he dismissed them
because after all, he was only firing blanks.
Daniel Day Lewis is arguably one of the
most Method actors of all time. Whether
it's spending an entire shoot in
a wheelchair for "My Left Foot,"
learning to track and skin animals for "Last
of the Mohicans," or staying in a solitary
prison cell for two nights for "In the Name
of the Father," the man commits to a role.
It's no surprise, then, that he got fully
into character to play one of his most
unforgettable characters — violent, angry oilman
Daniel Plainview in 2007's critically acclaimed
"There Will Be Blood." Many remember the moment
of Day Lewis lecturing Paul Dano's character…
"I drink your milkshake!"
[slurping sound]
But what viewers may not realize
is that this climactic scene was
actually quite dangerous
to film. Ever the realist,
Day Lewis insisted on throwing actual bowling
balls at Dano, who just barely got out of the way.
The realism certainly added to the moment, helping
create an authentic and iconic film moment.
An action series like "The Hunger Games" requires
a lot of safety planning due to all the stunts,
but the most dangerous, and unpleasant, scene to
film may surprise you. While Jennifer Lawrence
made headlines after accidentally kicking Josh
Hutcherson in the head and Liam Hemsworth hurt his
ankle while filming "Mockingjay Part II," it was
the sewer scene that really put people in danger.
In spite of having a sewer built on a
soundstage, director Francis Lawrence decided
to do the scene on location in a real sewer.
The water was heated, the ceilings were low,
which wasn't ideal for the 6'3” Liam Hemsworth,
and costumes got water-logged, adding at least
20 extra pounds on top of the actors. Plus,
being in an actual sewer isn't exactly sanitary,
which led to a quite miserable three-week shoot
for everyone. But in the end, they got the
footage — and in the unique realm of Hollywood,
sometimes that need transcends everything else.
Since its 1971 release, "Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory" has inspired the dreams
of countless kids and grown-ups alike. Willy
Wonka's iconic chocolate river in particular
stands out as a place of fun
and fantasy. But filming in
this candy wonderland wasn't quite
as wondrous as viewers might think.
According to Michael Bollner,
who played Augustus Gloop,
this dream was a bit of a nightmare. It was
"stinky water," made of 150,000 gallons of water,
cream, chocolate — and leftover coffee
dumped by folks on set. The stench of
the river only got worse over time, as the
cream spoiled during the course of the shoot.
Bollner had to do multiple takes, spending
the day soaked in his smelly clothes. Each
take required him to go back up into the tube,
where he was stuck with water up to his mouth.
The filming of this scene was so problematic
that Peter Ostrum, who played Charlie Bucket,
noted that OSHA likely had not
approved such working conditions.
It's not just action films that can
prove dangerous for actors and extras.
The physical nature of some comedies can
also create opportunities galore for people
to get injured, which was the case for Mike
Myers and Dana Carvey in "Wayne's World."
Who can hear Queen's "Bohemian Rhapsody"
without thinking of the classic scene from
the first "Wayne's World" movie? Myers fought
to have that song included in the movie,
instead of the original pick of Guns n' Roses,
and it paid off by becoming one of the
most iconic music scenes of all time.
According to Myers, though, it wasn't all fun
and games. The guys in The Mirthmobile got
very into the moment, and director Penelope
Spheeris needed many takes to get proper
coverage for all the various angles you see
in the scene. As a result, that scene took
almost an entire night to shoot, leading to
some serious neck pain. As Carvey told Rolling
Stone in 2015, he was 36 at the time and needed
more than a few Advil to get through the night.
Filming this sequence might have
been a headache for the actors,
but fans everywhere had the same
reaction to the final scene.
"Excellent."
"Ishtar" has gone down in film history
as one of Hollywood's greatest bombs,
and trouble plagued it from production to
release. The 1987 adventure comedy stars
Warren Beatty, Dustin Hoffman and Isabel
Adjani, and was filmed on location in
Morocco. What could go wrong with a handful
of warring egos, intense climate conditions,
and high political tensions in North Africa?
Actually, a lot could go wrong — and it did.
The film became infamous for its extravagant
over-spending and director Elaine May's high
number of takes. Perhaps the most dangerous scene
was the one where Hoffman lies in the desert,
surrounded by vultures. In order to get the
large, frightening birds to fly down around
him, production placed raw pieces of meat on
Hoffman's body, just out of frame. Hoffman asked…
"Are these vultures going to know
where the raw meat ends and I start?"
Unfortunately for him, he had
to do 50 takes to find out.
"The Conqueror," a 1956 John Wayne film, may be
one of the most surprisingly dangerous films in
history, although you wouldn't know it to
see it. In the early years of the Cold War,
the US created the Nevada Test Site and in
1951 started testing its nuclear weapons. Due
to the winds, the brunt of the nuclear
fallout was felt in St. George, Utah.
When producers of "The Conqueror" decided to film
in St. George, they did so with the assurance of
the federal government that the nuclear test site
posed no hazard to public health. Ultimately,
every scene of the film that was shot in St.
George proved to be incredibly dangerous.
By 1963, director Dick Powell died of cancer
and by 1980, 91 people from the production,
41 percent, developed the disease. Some say
that Wayne got cancer from this production,
although The Duke believed it was from
his six-pack-a-day cigarette habit.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.